did you accept that the challenge from
that muslim dawa guy
from speaker's corner please confirm or
deny that
um recently like over the past i don't
know
two months there's been a bunch from
speaker's corners guys
um uh adnan rasheed someone named
muhammad hijab or something like that
and ali
da wow so i've seen those guys
now one of those guys i know adnan
rasheed i know i'm familiar with him the
other two guys
uh don't worry you're gonna get to know
hijab as well
and uh if it makes anyone feel any
better i will debate all three of them
on the same stage at the same time
so please please please instead of
debating all fields just debate one of
us
on the matter of trinity and tahit
that's all we want from we're not free
you're a brave man
you've scared us because he likes the
number three obviously
but according to him all three of us are
one anyways
i don't know how i can say it any more
clearly than that ladies and gentlemen
i've been affirming that i'm willing to
debate all day long
and uh multiple times over the past
month so
uh anyone who asks go ahead and send
them back to that little clip right
there yes the answer is yes do you know
what he has to do now he has to send he
has to make a video
yeah put my name in the title yep with
your time
and your place like khabib says just
send me location brother
just send me location all right brother
sisters share this video with him we're
ready
america australia mars neptune as long
as we have oxygen
we will debate it send us location give
us locations